ينضم الينا من سوتش مدير مكتب الجزيره
زاور شاوش طبعا هجوم لاذعه على الغرب
اتهمه بانه ما كان يصل لما وصل اليه لولا
سرقت الكره الارضيه بحسب تعبير الرئيس
الروسي لكن ماذا عن بقيه ما جاء في الخطب
نعم ربما كما ذكرت زين العابدين بوتين
استغلها المناسبه بحضور خبراء اجانب
انهال بي انتقاداته على الغرب على السياسه
الاستعماريه القديمه والجديده انتقد
العالم المبني على القواعد التي لا يعرفها
سوى الغرب بقياده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه القواعد التي يريد الغرب
براي بوتين ان يفرضها على الدول الاخرى
الدول المختلفه الدول الباحثه عن سياسات
مستقله عن عالم متعدد الاقطاب عالم فيهم
يعني تتساوى فيه ليس فقط الدول من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه وايضا من الناحيه
الحضاريه للحضارات متنوعه ولا تفوق لحضاره
على اخرى ولكن ايضا اشار الى نقطه مهمه
انه في كل مره تسعى فيها دول الاستعماريه
لفرض قوانين سياسيه قوانين اقتصاديه
وقوانين اخلاقيه
العالم بحرب شامله بحرب عالميه وفي هذا
اشاره مباشره الى ان العالم اليوم براي
الرئيس الروسي على شفا حفره مواجهه واسعه
حرب يمكن ان تؤدي بيع البشريه الى الفناء
كونه في هذا العالم يوجد من الوسائل
التدميريه بحسب بوتين ما يكفي الى تدمير
الكوكب بوتين اعتبر ان العالم في الصيغه
التي تريدها واشنطن وحليفاتها لا يمكن ان
يستمر وان عالما جديدا يتكون عالم مبني
على تعدديه الاخطاب على احترام المصالح
وانه لا بديل لهذا العالم والا فان الكوكب
سيشهد صراعات كثيره وانما يجري الان هو
بدرجه الاولى ان كان في في اوكرانيا وحتى
في مرات اخرى من العالم هو نتيجه الرفض
عدد دول او عده قوى لمركزيه القرار
ولهيمنه العالم الغربي اذا بوتين اليوم
بحسب قال حدث باسم الكلمه سيكون له
تصريحات مهمه في غضون هذه الجلسه التي
بدات الان بخطاب وسيستمر بعدها في حوار مع
المشاركين في نادي فالدار وكما عودنا
بوتين في هذا الحوار السنوي ان يكون لمده
طويله وان تكون هناك تصريحات ربما تظهر
مواقف متعلقه بقضايا اساسيه متعلقه
بالدرجه الاولى بالتوازن الاستراتيجي في
العالم التعدديه القطبيه مساله الاسلحه
النوويه وايضا ازمه الغذاء في العالم
اضافه طبعا الى ملف اوكرانيا سيكون حاضرا
وايضا ما الملفات الاقليميه الاخرى وعلى
راسها الوضع حول اقليم كارباخ شكرا